for the
audience out there fangs facebook amazon
apple netflix and google it's really
you know from the time the iphone was
came into view in 2007
over 10 years they they moved from
being nowhere to being now 25 percent of
the
standard poor index
and and that means they have huge
outsized
control over the global information
economy not but not only that
you know they are really the targets
that the chinese communist party goes
after so baidu
uh is essentially google alibaba is
essentially amazon and tencent is
facebook and so their goal is
essentially to take baidu alibaba
and tencent and through dominating the
5g platform
and being able to be the first to bring
those apps and services and business
models to market
to then use that to pole vault over the
top of the thing so you just
talked about how dangerous it would be
if the us
you know basically used the data that
the fans collect and their
and their ability to mine that data for
information and and create
influential algorithms but that's
exactly what the chinese are doing
and the bats baidu alibaba and tencent
have those same technologies except they
are controlled by
an authoritarian regime that essentially
wants to use that data for exactly those
things so
i mean this we're on the precipice of
you know a transformational
time in in not only geopolitics but only
but also in preserving our republic so
we're close to the 250 years where
most republics um essentially
disintegrate so the the question
i think that's so important that you're
alluding to is can we adapt
to the world that we created that has
basically been weaponized against us and
this is
this is where i think you know both you
and i have been focused on for
you know the last three years and i
think it's going to take you know
another
10 to really determine whether or not
the us survives as a democracy how many
democracies
actually can you know make the
transition from understanding how to
protect the
sovereignty and independence in the
physical world
or as our as you say the energy or the
oil
of the 21st century being data you know
can we
can we can we manage to transition and
protect ourselves
in the same way that we protected the
united states you know in the in world
war one and world war
ii in the cold war but using different
tools that
really have nothing to do with bombs and
bullets you know it's it's
can we um deal with the fact that as
kaifu lee
says and kaifu lee is a leading
artificial intelligence thinker in
china you know they intend
and are on the way to becoming the saudi
arabia of data
what does that mean for us when they can
take all of that data
which means theirs and ours and then put
it in
algorithms that really allow them to
pull the levers behind the scenes in
ways that we're not even
we don't even perceive it's happening
right now in our own
you know run up to a 2020 campaign
something that i'm completely
um you know terrified by because i think
that we we're not in position to
actually defend ourselves from it
no i don't i don't disagree with you it
is uh
uh the 250-year republic you know was a
interesting comment and yeah i sometimes
wonder are we uh
you know you know rome seems to have a
lot of analogy right
you know when i think of it in in that
way but
but we did invent a lot of these tools
and services and if we can get back and
and this is where to me when we talk
about
re when i and i mentioned
reindustrialization earlier to me it's
not just
you know bringing it's not bringing back
manufacturing the way manufacturing used
to be it's
it's also bringing back our ingenuity
and our technological innovation
on how manufacturing you know should
look in the future right i mean look at
look at tesla and look at elon musk and
you know some of the the factories out
and uh
that they're you know factor of the
future that they're are working on is a
model that you know will
still creates jobs still creates jobs
and you know high you know higher
skilled jobs but
but it's a great example of where the
two worlds are are kind of coming
together and i think that also has to
happen in
in silicon valley as well is that it's
okay to get back to building
infrastructure
i look at it as simply simplistically as
you know
having been in the software world when
we used to build you know a lot of the
infrastructures that you're
you're designing and thinking of the
innovation infrastructure running eye
towards the services
that you want to enable in the future
but if you're not designing and building
the infrastructure
for what it is you want to enable in the
future you're just sitting back waiting
for someone to tell you
what it is they did and that gets back
to just sitting back waiting for
you know whether it's china or someone
else to say hey tell us what the
tell us about that next wave of
infrastructure is going to be like so i
can start thinking about creative
business model and more algorithms
that does not push forward our the
economic interest
interests of you know of the country as
a whole right or the labor
market for the country as a whole and i
think technologists
have far more you know influence over
uh you know the infrastructure and
you know contribution to the
reindustrialization of the country than
they realize i think we can we tend to
think of
it as being you know i'm trying to just
save uh you know a manufacturing plant
who's a cabinet maker
you know in pennsylvania or something
which you know a lot of great people who
are losing their jobs and
but it i think it it to me it bleeds
over into the technology as well and i
think when
when we can start to bridge the gap
between
uh those two uh uh
you know industries or our points of
view if you will
then then the us will have a chance but
right now
uh we're getting our butts handed to us
and we just don't want to admit it
because we
all feel like our 401ks are doing well
and stock markets up
but you know go peel back the stock
market and say well if i go take out
the fangs out of the stock market is the
market really way up the way it seems
i i think we're just we're drinking
[Music]
kool-aid